the question to me is not can we
eventually at some point in the future
recreate human intelligence the question
to me is
why would we want to do that in the
first place
when we can create something different
so it shouldn't be our goal to recreate
ourselves it's actually more useful to
create something that's supplemental
and i actually just wrote a book called
the new breed that tries to challenge
and break this mold of subconsciously
thinking of robots like humans by
offering a different analogy
this is an analogy that is familiar to
us that acknowledges that robots are
different from toasters in that they can
make their own decisions and learn about
the world and it's one that changes some
of these conversations and what i think
are pretty important ways
so if we come back to the baby seal
robot the paro
pardo is not designed to replace human
caregivers what paro is designed to
replace is animal therapy in contexts
where we can't use real animals for
reasons of health and hygiene and safety
but we can use the robot and it works
because people will consistently treat
the robot more like an animal than a
device
and it's not just in the social robotics
context if you think about it throughout
history we've used animals for work for
weaponry for companionship we
domesticated them because their skill
sets are different from ours not because
they do what we do
because they're different and that's
useful we've used oxen to plow our
fields for millennia we've used horses
to travel the world in new ways
here is the original hobby photography
drone in the early 1900s there was a
german pharmacist who was using pigeons
to deliver medicine which is something
we're starting to do with drones in
remote locations today and one day he
had the wild idea to put cameras on the
pigeons to see if they could take aerial
photographs
and turns out they could and of course
later the cia adopted this to create spy
pigeons but pigeons also delivered mail
for thousands of years letting us
communicate with each other in totally
new ways
now animals not only have physical
abilities but also sensing abilities
that are way better than ours and
incredibly useful
this for example is an official united
states navy echolocation device
in the 60s and 70s both the united
states and the soviet navy started
marine mammal training programs because
marine mammals have amazing echolocation
systems
so they use them to detect
lost underwater equipment and mines
there's some rumors that they strapped
harpoons to them and made them into
weapons as well
but the united states also used both
robots and dolphins in the gulf wars to
look for minds
and in fact the dolphin program is still
in place because even though they've
tried to phase out the dolphins and
replace them with robots the dolphins
are still in many ways better than the
technology
here's also the
original sensory equipment used in the
mines the canary in the coal mine and i
could go on and on right there are so
many examples of how we are using
robots today in roles that we've
previously used animals in but the point
that i want to make is not that animals
and robots are the same the point that i
want to make is that
moving away from this constant
quasi-human comparison opens our minds
to new possibilities it's a really
useful thought exercise it helps
challenge the idea that robots in ai can
will or should replace people
the true potential of robotics and
artificial intelligence is not to
recreate what we already have it's for
us to partner with these technologies
and what we're trying to achieve